a lot of women I would rather had rather
had to the woman than they did with a
man like I've been told that light and
because they felt like what man is more
like getting a so forth don't care men
do wanna please women but do you have
most men that's just like yeah let's get
it and go that's correct I think that
generally speaking men are more
concerned about their pleasure than
their concern about women sure the
reason why is because yo ladies is very
complicated so people are gonna be
people are gonna give up the man that
that that take care of themselves they
really gonna have this mentality if I'm
responsible of getting off you
responsible you getting off so I think
they give up like that for that the big
thing is if you know how to will get you
off you have to be communicative about
that you have to be able to say it
there's this thing where if man have all
the pressure of yay if you didn't come
it's because he's not good in bed and
his name is just that's nothing to do
with the woman it's always the man that
that has this burden where he's
responsible of getting you off I think
the global context that sometimes people
miss is that for a long time women have
been shamed for their desires and so
that stuff is past generation to
generation that trauma still lives on
and it shows itself in the inability of
women to communicate and I would
encourage anyone who's you know with a
woman to even if she doesn't express her
displeasure in the bedroom she may not
be at a point where she feels
comfortable enough to say that you know
there's been plenty of times where I've
been you know sleeping with a woman and
I'm asking her if this position is okay
and she says yeah but I can tell she's
in pain but in her head she's
internalized that like oh this is how
the experience is supposed to be and I'm
like it doesn't have to be that way I
don't have to derive pleasure from your
pain did you did what I'm saying so try
to initiate that conversation as a man
because we don't have those in ambitions
as much as they do I try to always
initiate that conversation be like I'll
listen don't hesitate to say what you're
feeling and if I can sense that
hesitation ologist asking like is this
okay for you because if it's not just
say that it's okay and I think if you
lay down that groundwork you're going to
see them communicate far more with you
with what they like
what they want to try all that stuff so
my message to men is just lay down that
groundwork for that communication
because they may not be at a point yet
where they're ready to men are selfish
in bed and they're selfish in bed for a
few different reasons one being that
they're never really instructed on how
to please a woman even the prom they
consume is all about male pleasure all
the time that's what I'm saying no
that's not you're saying it's yet you
know you're saying they're selfish
because women have it taught them I'm
telling you has nothing to do with women
it's not about just making a woman come
it's not just about getting her off
making her feel good it's also part of
that problem I'm saying is that what I
said I also said is that man women don't
instruct men what I'm trying to tell you
is that most men don't even make the
effort to pay attention oh yeah that's
that's that's what it is yeah absolutely
when men don't make the effort that's it
that's that that's again that's I could
say yesterday I can say you say that but
there's I think it's deeper than that as
well
it's not just they don't make the effort
it's really the fact that was age of
Ages of being instructed that we don't
have to I mean it's really easier for us
to get off than theirs for them but they
again
so it is their fault it's not women's
will to a certain degree it's not to a
certain degree it is men's fault if they
don't want to be empathetic yes that
argue with that's your response what
that reset with that sentence yeah
totally I realized how bad bad men were
when I made little effort in bed and
women were blown away oh yeah II
understand is that when you get in a
relationship and you guys to go so how's
your day she's like you want to know
what yeah if you want a good to
experience generally a good basis to
start forth as a man is take care of her
first and get choice afterwards because
hers is a lot harder to get and you can
get yours at any point this really just
sounds like a firmer shil for your
prowess man my what information for your
prowess I just think that whenever
people talk about in bed they often go
to orgasms and to me it's like it's a
lot larger than that you can have second
experiences in your day-to-day life
which don't involve an orgasm since
could be really great and I think
oftentimes men fixate themselves on how
a woman is pleased whether or not she
comes and I can assure you you can have
orgasms and still have terrible acts and
so I always try to tell man like yo
focus on the other [ __ ] that's happened
in the bedroom
because if you do then you'll start to
realize okay this person's actually
enjoyed this they're enjoying that
because I'm not just fixated on going
down on the girl I know whatever it may
be there's a lot of other aspects that
happen in the bedroom like I member
meaning women who like you when it comes
to kissing or surprised by a lot of
stuff I'm like what do you do with these
dudes and look I don't talk to my male
friends I've never asked pre sex
what are your moves in the bedroom
because you know that's none of your
goddamn business
yeah and we don't gossip gossip like
like you ladies oh we don't you know it
does tell us our special moves oh who
what yeah but we're like we're like Oh
God
okay all done that's one dude that's not
you know it's funny though he treats his
moves like there's political statements
that when he said piece of dead polish
we got an example you said I'm doing it
for the ancestors that might be the only
guy I know who's ever told me his moves
in my entire life
that's interesting did I wonder like if
women when they're socialized as a young
age are they thinking about because me
growing up nobody ever really talked to
me about eating the Box none of the
stuff that men recommended I tried
involved their pleasure
it was always centered her on her own
I'm wondering if women are socialized in
a way that their sense of good sex and
all that stuff is about getting a man
off duty what I'm saying I mean me it
was never like it was really never about
you first time I had you know you don't
you do your thing and she looks at Shula
and look at you you did you did that
this is what I'm doing this is having
that face that oh if I could do that
okay so it's just I definitely think it
is I was more I was I was more gentleman
than most people I know right I mean so
I was making sure everything was all
right and good maybe I asked you too
many questions because maybe that's
because I was surrounded with women and
you know they will I heard stories
that's a matter of culture in the
environment because like there's a
country I think it's Rwanda if I
remember correctly but they have a whole
documentary about men
[Music]
[Applause]
mmm Akira an era una hora
[Music]
what yeah and so in that country I'm
sure if you surveyed them women
satisfaction would probably be much
higher because for men it's a sense of
pride to be that empathetic and to make
her you know they talk about the the the
waterfalls and they talk about all that
stuff you know saying I'll go say no and
so it's definitely culturally great
we're here not only do we still live in
a very puritanical society where we've
seen people we are not a country that
wants to openly talk about and what that
looks like for different the different
genders generational as well not an
older Asian man don't eat the box
culturally Ladda Jamaican not eat the
box
Mima like fish so let me eat the box
yeah here it is even salt about that no
no no no no way this is all about yeah
if you're a bad man you don't eat you
eat that's a myth there's plenty
Jamaican men who do it the bomb yeah and
they don't say it they just say they
don't faith they're like the opposite of
home they're in the box they're in the
closet in the box
imagine because our gonna be bad about
you know men are not cross Jamaican
women will be in the comments me like I
know that's not yeah and people who [ __ ]
with Jamaicans are gonna say I know
that's not sure yeah there's gonna be
people that eat the box so I guess if we
have to give any solutions to this
problem women try to communicate the
fact that you know like well preach ed
levy aside you guys should communicate
more the fact that you want certain
things done men you should be more in
pathetic this is something you share
with somebody else and if you just treat
as a penetrative experience then you are
not doing that other person justice and
not yourself also because once you take
care of her the whole experience is
heightened yeah just a home invasion
yeah if you just what it's just a home
invasion wait I agree to somebody
nowhere yeah it's just a holiday so that
yeah yeah huh what home invasion
if you don't pleasure you know you just
go in and then do your thing and leave
you have to okay okay yeah I met ah it's
the kind of burglar who just comes in
jerking on your pictures and doesn't see
me this right that's not a burglar it's
a home invasion yeah with some minor
vandalism yeah yeah about to paint these
walls can you say the word prawn prawn
why probably just sub it over every word
to me time you say porn is it all we
don't eat the wussy but let's see what
they would be can't you see sometimes
the word whoopee whoopee whoopee can't
you see sometimes the man's a really
lazy
[Music]
I think during the video as I was
editing it I realized how my tone was
dismissive of preach and how maybe like
overly upset I was getting and I think
part of that is because the fact that
you know no preachers been with his girl
for a long time and I've been on the
other end where I've dated quite a few
women and I've seen those women's
struggles in the bedroom and all that
and so I think I became super sensitive
to it and I almost came to a point like
damn this is really messed up that they
go through that so when I think I
internalize what preachers saying as him
being extremely dismissive and I reacted
negative to it and you know we sort
through through that we're good now
but I just watched my tone and I was
kind of I guess disappointed and so
those are things about myself that I'm
gonna have to fix and try to make more
of an effort to not be that way going
forward but yeah I just wanted to leave
that little note because I wanted to let
you guys know that I am constantly
assessing my behavior how I talk and
trying to be better